come avrete capito questa sera sono un
po un pesce fuor d'acqua
non vi annoierò con i miei soliti
discorsi di greco e di latino quello che
faccio tutti i giorni all'università ma
vi vorrei parlare di una passione che io
porto avanti in maniera in maniera
amatoriale
ora io ho raccontato qualcosa su di me
raccontatemi voi qualcosa partiamo da
una domanda molto semplice chi tra voi
suona uno strumento musicale sulle mani
se le mani non le vedo giu
seconda domanda più difficile chi tra
voi sono uno strumento musicale insieme
in un coro in una banda in un'orchestra
in un gruppo sulle mani siamo un po di
meno
siamo un po di meno come queste persone
pensano non è la stessa cosa a suonare
suonare insieme e per farvelo capire ho
scelto un esempio un esempio molto
semplice quasi quasi banale chi conosce
la musica riconoscerà subito con le due
righe di pentagramma e lino una gioia
chi conosce il tedesco riconoscerà anche
le parole il killer che calzano a
pennello per la serata parlano di unità
della gioia che riunisce i fratelli
infatti sono state scelte come inno
dell'europa unita
ora a partire da queste due righe di
musica che tutti conoscono
da questa melodia famosissima vorrei
provarmi a far capire quanto sia diverso
suonare e suonare insieme
ho scelto degli esempi molto semplici
come tutti sappiamo un in una gioia e
una composizione di beethoven nella nona
sinfonia tuttavia poco tempo dopo liste
ne produsse una trascrizione per
pianoforte
era una musica troppo bella per evitare
di poterla eseguire anche da soli nel
salotto di casa si usava nell'ottocento
cosa succede la trascrizione per
pianoforte ovviamente non è la stessa
cosa nella composizione orchestrale e
dal confronto di queste due versioni
spero di farvi capire quanto sia diverso
per chi ascolta la musica da soli era
musica d'insieme per riposare un
pochettino la voce mi faccio sentire
degli estratti questo è quello di vista
[Musica]
poche sorprese la conoscevamo tutti però
proviamo ad ascoltare l'originale di
beethoven
[Musica]
già ne sentiamo la differenza però il
livello finale si raggiunge nella
conclusione della sinfonia quando
all'orchestra si aggiunge il coro e
quindi abbiamo il confronto perfetto tra
una e 100 persone che suonano
esattamente la stessa cosa
[Applauso]
[Musica]
insomma la differenza è chiara per chi
ascolta avete sentito quanta potenza di
suono in più hanno 100 persone rispetto
ad una ma anche quali possibilità
armonica maggiore c'è 100 persone
possono fare almeno 100 note diverse un
pianoforte per quanto si sforzi più di
dieci non ne fa e infine si potrebbe
fare un altro paragone
insomma la versione per orchestra e un
quadro con colori ad olio bellissimi
sgargianti
la versione per pianoforte quando si
sono adesso che sostanzialmente è uno
schizzo a matita in bianco e nero c'è lo
stesso un apporto di colori ciascuna
voce ciascuno strumento porta il suo
contributo che è insostituibile
però se abbiamo capito che per chi
ascolta la differenza è lampante
forse non tutti sanno quanto sia grande
la differenza dall'altra parte per chi
suona quanto sia diverso suonare da soli
o suonare insieme
vi ho portato alcuni esempi ci sono
delle caratteristiche che chi sono
insieme in una banda in un'orchestra 80
in un coro acquisisce quasi
immediatamente
le prime sono legate a esigenze molto
molto pratiche serve prontezza serve
perspicacia per capire quale sia il
momento giusto per attaccare quando
fermarsi quando suonare più forte o più
piano quando rallentare per aspettare il
compagno quando andare più veloci per
aumentare il ritmo però questi
accorgimenti pragmatici sono subordinati
in generale alla capacità di ascoltare
di ascoltarsi la capacità di individuare
quel sistema di tensioni all'interno del
quale inserirsi in maniera armonica al
momento giusto nel modo giusto
questo ascolto porta anche alla modestia
nessuno è solista per tutto il brano
quando si sono insieme la parte del
protagonista
ce l'hanno un po tutti a rotazione e la
compagna e una dura necessità ma va pur
fatta perché ci sia armonia quindi
suonando insieme si impara anche a
rimanere al proprio posto a rispettare
il posto dell'altro
e proprio questo rispetto per l'altro è
la caratteristica principale che vorrei
sottolineare questa sera
che secondo me si impara in maniera
lampante suonando insieme vi ho portato
un esempio molto pedestre anche in
questo caso che forse aiuta a fissare
questo concetto
guardate queste due immagini io non
trovo grande differenza quando si sono
da soli è come andare per strada senza
altre automobili la mia libertà e
autonoma sono io
di fronte al codice della strada o di
fronte alla partitura e devo tirare
fuori da quello che è scritto la mia
musica non o limitazioni che non siano
me stesso e le regole costituite quando
però mi ritrovo a suonare insieme agli
altri
la situazione è molto più simile a un
ingorgo stradale al traffico che si
trova nell'ora di punta
e nonostante ci possa essere un vigile
urbano ora non se ne vedono più in mezzo
all'incrocio che provi a gestire la
situazione così come c'è un direttore
sul podio dell'orchestra che prova a far
andare tutti insieme la mia libertà non
è più autonoma la mia libertà è
subordinato la libertà degli altri
devo trovare il punto giusto in questo
insieme armonioso per inserirmi tenendo
conto di quello che l'altro deve fare
può fare o vorrebbe fare la mia libertà
diventa in funzione della libertà
dell'altro
proprio questo rispetto dell'altro porta
uno conoscenza dell'altro
cosa significa per capire qual è il mio
momento devo conoscere il momento
dell'altro
devo conoscere che cosa è richiesto
all'altro e che cosa può fare l'altro
che sta suonando con me vi ho riportato
una vecchia massima che gira nell'ambito
dei musicisti
le prove sono il momento non per
imparare la propria parte ma quelle
degli altri
conoscendo la parte degli altri io sarò
anche in grado di capire qual è il
momento di suonare la mia la conoscenza
dell'altro e il grande valore che nasce
dal rispetto per lui e la cosa è
reciproca
conoscendolo lo si impara a rispettare
vi parlo molto brevemente
dell'esperienza con cui sono entrato
all'interno del mondo della musica
d'insieme così in profondità
grazie all'aiuto di alcuni amici qualche
anno fasano ho potuto partecipare al
laboratorio di musica da camera per
ottoni in california è un'esperienza a
dir poco straordinaria 80 persone le più
diverse che possiate immaginare per età
e per formazione musicisti
professionisti quasi nessuno
tanti studenti ma anche persone che
suonano per hobby senza alcun problema
ci siamo ritrovati lì per due settimane
a sperimentare cosa si intende con
questo ogni mattina venivano creati dei
gruppi nuovi diversi i gruppi
cameristici tre quartetti quintetti
gruppi da 7 dalle 8 fino ai dei cimini
ogni giorno diversi con persone diverse
che non si conoscevano tra loro e
accadeva precisamente questo veniva
assegnata della musica che ogni giorno
cambiata degli spartiti da leggere
sostanzialmente a prima vista
c'era una giornata di tempo con le prove
per preparare un brano non lunghissimo
insomma 45 minuti di musica da
presentare la sera ma un piccolo
spettacolo ogni gruppo presentava il
lavoro fatto e in quella circostanza che
ho capito quale sia la difficoltà di
imparare a suonare insieme di ritrovarsi
di fronte a persone che vedevo per la
prima volta e trovare il punto
d'incontro per collaborare quali sono i
vantaggi educativi di ritrovarsi in
situazioni come queste di ritrovarsi di
fronte allo spartito con persone che
sono sostanzialmente alla alla mia
altezza tra pari
si innesca quel procedimento di
apprendimento che è in qualche modo
alternativo a quello che conosciamo di
solito noi quando ci immaginiamo un
insegnante immaginiamo una cattedra
dalla quale un professore o comunque chi
sa insegna a chi non sa c'è un
dislivello
c'è chi sa che c'è chi non sa qui invece
siamo di fronte a una situazione di
apprendimento orizzontale siamo
grossomodo tutti alla pari
di fronte alla partitura e entrano in
gioco tutti quei meccanismi con cui io
posso imparare da chi è alla mia stessa
altezza senza un dislivello
io posso osservare chi è vicino a me
imitarlo se vedo che quel comportamento
funziona
nell'economia generale o posso una volta
scoperto un errore una mancanza
correggerlo senza dislivelli ma la paris
fraternamente e queste sono tutte
strategie che vanno sotto la etichetta
generale di apprendimento orizzontale
che io ho ritrovato nel mondo
dell'università
nel mondo della scuola ma che immagino
non saranno granché diverse da quelle
che dovrò imparare a utilizzare nel
mondo del lavoro e in generale nelle
relazioni che costelleranno la mia vita
è il laboratorio principale in cui si
possono imparare queste strategie sono
una delle ricchezze più grandi del
nostro territorio la vallesina pullula
di associazioni musicali cori bande
musicali orchestre gruppi sono le fucine
in cui si apprendono queste strategie di
apprendimento orizzontale si apprendono
tutte quelle caratteristiche che la
musica di insegne di insieme insegna è
una ricchezza che non possiamo lasciarci
lasciarci sfuggire
e proprio da questo ambiente delle bande
musicali dei cori delle orchestre viene
l'ultima massima che vi vorrei lasciare
l'ultimo massimo è molto semplice ma
forse mette un po in crisi quello che ho
detto finora dalle mie parole sembrerà
che nella musica d'insieme funziona
tutto basta andare d'accordo
basta essere in sintonia non è così
semplice
l'armonia e una tensione e una tensione
che si realizza al momento giusto
infatti non basta andare d'accordo non
basta a produrre sintonia
bisogna gestire i disaccordi nella
musica in base al vecchio principio del
contrappunto esistono canti e
controcanti voci che non si
appiattiscono l'una sull'altra voci
irrimediabilmente diverse
quante volte ci capita nella vita di
trovare qualcuno che non la pensa come
noi e che non vuol sentir ragioni per
cambiare la sua idea
ecco la musica d'insieme insegna tirar
fuori l'armonia da questo tipo di
situazioni situazioni in cui la
diversità che non è discordia può essere
armonizzata può essere condotta a
livello di musica sinfonica di suono
insieme grazie
[Applauso]